but Nevada teenager who was shot by a
school police officer has spoken
publicly for the first time about what
happened cell phone video captured Logan
Clark waving knives at fellow students
moments before he was shot in the chest
in December a subsequent stroke in the
hospital left him with severe brain
trauma it affects his speech and
requires him to wear a helmet for
protection maria vio has an interview
with the teenager and his family that
you'll see only on CBS this morning
how are you feeling talking is tough for
Logan Clark these days but he has no
trouble remembering the morning of
December 7 cell phone video captured the
14 year old waving two knives into a
crowd of students at hug High School in
Reno moments later a school district
officer fired a single shot when you
went to school that day did you feel
like you had to protect yourself yep
Clark's mother and grandmothers say he
took the weapons to school after
repeated bullying when you hear people
say that bringing a knife to school
isn't the answer to bullying how do you
respond to that it's not the answer but
to a fourteen-year-old kid I guess it is
the date you know not to hurt anybody
with the knives
but just to get them off of you I'm not
defending my son bringing knives to
school whatsoever but what I ask myself
is what makes the school officer think
that it's okay to shoot my son the Reno
Police Department said Clark had been
involved in a fight with another student
that day and that the school district
officer opened fire after the teen
acknowledged him and ignored commands to
drop the knives
David Houston is the family's attorney
do you believe he heard the officer I do
not believe that environment would allow
Logan to have heard the police officer a
day after the shooting Washoe County
School Superintendent Tracy Davis
praised responding officers for keeping
the other students safe had it not been
for their quick actions and
professionalism I truly believe that the
outcome could have been
why not use a Taser why not shoot him in
the foot and having other kids standing
around behind Logan and could have
struck another another kid the name of
the officer has not been released and in
a statement the school district told CBS
this morning because the incident in
question is still under investigation by
an outside police agency we are unable
to provide any information at this time
do you miss school yeah do you miss your
friends yeah do you want to go back
though you know not there officials are
now conducting two separate
investigations to determine whether the
shooting was justified and if charges
should be brought against the school
officers or the student with that
possibility out there how do you respond
to that that you know being shot and
almost dying that would be kind of like
punishment enough for CBS this morning
midday ovule Reno Nevada so tragic a
tough story that's a really tough story